part of this is you have the pleasure of
talking to what I'll call the full stack
right everyone from somebody who is a
young person who wants to become a
leader in an organization to somebody
who is kind of we'll call it middle
management or middle of their career and
maybe happy where they are and just want
to get some better performance or may
not be happy and kind of want to
accelerate but then you also talk to the
absolute best in the world as well and
so as you've been doing this what are
some of the things that you've noticed
the best investors traders what do they
do that separates them from everybody
else is it simple things or they
complexin nuance like that the top 1%
what separates them mentally from
everybody else well if it's market
investing in Cheney they understand the
market it's just a social game that
there's no like absolute then it's
really just perception like in its waves
of the ocean of perception changing and
so they're they're trading against other
people's perception and whatever you
know however they analyze it whether
they use technical analysis and charts
or fundamentals and you know value
that's just like a clue to how people's
perception is changing so they just
understand the market as human beings
like waves and inertia and it's a really
different way to like to have
internalized market plus they use their
feelings I mean they really do use their
feelings like they know that conviction
is an emotion and they can tell the
difference between when they're
convicted and something for the right
reasons or when they're like agitated
and compelled to do something but it's
for the wrong reasons like you know
another investment didn't go well the
IRS showed up or like in my mind they're
using them they're using on their brain
the way the human brain is really
designed which is
something I think neuroscience is really
just starting to reveal to us and kind
of the assumptions we've had about it
centuries it's all wrong
but they like intuitively come to that
like they through their experience they
they get the model of what's happening
right and they get like the mechanism of
how thinking about it works best right
and do you feel like that that almost it
sounds like it reduces the pressure of
some of the decision-making right if
there are no absolutes if you're simply
playing this social game and the market
is a signal of how everyone within that
market feels it feels like that's a
little bit less of a pressure situation
then if I said to you you're gonna be
right or wrong on a daily basis is that
direct fact it's not like you have to
find a secret answer that's lurking out
there you know the cloud feeling that
you're searching for the Holy Grail
and more of a feeling that you're
circling and so it's like keep my
balance you know and in private the ways
and that is easier it is easier yeah and
would it be fair to say the other thing
that you said that I think I understand
is that the best in the world are
focused more on the decision making
process rather than the actual decisions
themselves I think that's true I'm not
sure I said it but I think that is true
that people have a given a strategy that
they do it once here they want to look
at it this way this way this way in
Texas Fox checks this box checked this
box now they also understand that
they're predicting an unknowable future
because that's what it is right none of
us know what's gonna happen half an hour
let alone them tomorrow and by the way
the brain works on a prediction
prediction
and ISM so again they're like in concert
as opposed to creating friction but we
always say that like knowing the way
that you interact with the market like
whatever your strategy is and sticking
with it is definitely the better way to
go around it so that's a process yeah
explain that more right so like is that
a discipline thing when you say kind of
understanding almost like your circle of
competency and just sticking to that
well it's how you understand owing
through what lens does the market makes
sense to you
like I'll often like on Twitter all but
I'll tell people you got your philosophy
of the market is and what your
philosophy of stops are you'll be like
what's she talking about maybe yeah
first of all we do everything based on
past experience in like the scaffolding
of beliefs so it helps to know what you
believe because like all the information
you're you're interpreting through your
beliefs so I'm saying look make sure you
know what you believe there are a
million different ways to make money in
the market you just have to figure out
like what yours is just like you know
there's a million different ways to play
football baseball basketball right like
we'll have there there's Pacific
combination was the same so you got to
figure out what that is
like how does the market make sense to
you like what's your analogy for it like
to surfing do it because it's not a
sport like but it's not a sport like
football or baseball and then how you
learn to stick with it and how do you
understand when you're confident in what
you're seeing and when you're not have
you learned to make choices when you're
reasonably confident but not too hot not
which is a process of knowing like your
own you know feeling it's like knowing
yourself